[Music]
I'll see you in h
baby would have gotten them all if they
W so fast they're not moving
Anya for their first family vacation the
forgers travel to the snow covered land
of
fries yummy careful wandering off we
don't want you getting lost it's a
special night so I think it's okay for
Anya to stay got past her bedtime that
trip you must retrieve the microfilm
without Fai ended up holding the fate of
the
world this will lead to warar between
East and
West what a nosy little girl kill
[Music]
her don't tell me Ana's gotten herself
mixed up with the military fire W's
coming anyway no matter what we can't
give up now if that microfilm ends up in
the wrong hands it could alter the fate
of the world uh-oh I'm in big trouble
let's do this as a family is that all
you've
got eliminate them said I'm going to
save them wait for me
Ana spy Family Code
white I'll get them back whatever it
takes
[Music]